julian quel fou kir secrétaire national
du parti de gauche et spécialiste de
l'amérique du sud
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dites nous quel impact a eu
le suicide de cette jeune colombienne
sur le mouvement de contestation jeune
fille et qui a accusé des policiers
d'agression sexuelle avant de mourir
bien cette cet événement encore plus mis
le feu à la poudrière si j'ose dire
puisque il a mis le doigt sur quelque
chose de profond en colombie qui est
l'injustice et l'impunité dont jouissent
certains enfin jouissent les policiers
les paramilitaires d'autres responsables
de l'ordre et qui réprime depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines le peuple colombien
la question des massacres la question
des violences contre les manifestants et
compris la question des violences
sexistes et sexuelles contre contre
certaines manifestantes
surtout qu'en plus ces manifestations
sont très générationnel c'est surtout la
jeune génération qui se mobilisent donc
difficilement qui a été très touché par
ce message de cette jeune femme qu'elle
a laissées sur les délits qui s'est
répandue sur les réseaux sociaux
du coup en plus approfondie le le le
sentiment anti orifices le sentiment de
révolte de la part de cette jeune
génération et de l'ensemble des des
manifestants est donc cet événement va
très certainement encore plus
radicalisés où j'ai si j'ose dire
approfondir justement ce mécontentement
contre le gouvernement le d'yvan bouquet
et laurie bismes de manière générale
réclame précisément le peuple colombien
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant
initialement le 11 avril s'était
concentrée sur la lite et bouddha donc
la réforme fiscale mais qui depuis a été
retiré suite à aux nombreuses
manifestations qui ont été d'ailleurs
aussi réprimées dans beaucoup de
violences notamment je pense à la à cali
où on avait vu on a vu un pic de
violence absolument inouïe et depuis les
manifestations les manifestants sont
allés sur un mode horde encore plus
général qui est sortir du pays laurie
wismes qui était du coup que rapport
appelé horrible et l'ancien président
colombien qui est un peu le véritable
président puisqu'il vient de qena un peu
qu'une marionnette delory bise qui est
le personnage principal de la droite
colombienne est aujourd'hui leurs
revendications principales de ces
manifestants c'est une revendication
dégage' c'est à dire on ne veut plus de
ces sociétés là on ne veut plus du rib
et ses copains ans de plutôt ribes et de
sa famille c'est contre un modèle que
les manifestants sont en train de
manifester succès serait pas forcément
contre une réforme en particulier c'est
contre un système
et comme j'ai dix cesser ses
manifestations sont touchées par un
phénomène très générationnel c'est
essentiellement la jeune génération qui
ne veut plus vivre de la même manière
que leurs anciens ont vécu c'est à dire
sous le marteau trafic la violence
politique la violence des paramilitaires
les assassiner politiques tous les jours
et ça depuis des dizaines d'années
depuis bientôt vingt ans dans un monde
et tous les jours d assassiner politique
en colombie
et donc ce ce mouvement de protestation
qui fait suite à celui de 2010 9 qui est
du cas du qui s'est arrêté à cause de la
pandémie est arrivé à un stade encore
plus encore plus profond et encore plus
on va dire que le général sur ce que
doit être la société colombienne ce
qu'est ce qui doit être promue pour pour
le com comme nouveau mode d'organisation
de la société colombienne
donc là il forcément une réforme il
centralise le la protestation mais
principalement la démission d'yvan tout
qu'est la faim daury wismes vers un
autre modèle de société ouvert deux
nouveaux représentants politiques la fin
de la corruption à la fin de la violence
politique la fin des violences sexistes
invite fin des violences sexistes et
sexuelles comme malheureusement on vient
de dans le lavoir un tri une triste
actualité
voilà en gros ce sur quoi se concentre
et sur quoi se polarise aujourd'hui les
manifestations conduit vous parliez de
la démission demandée par les
manifestants démission d'yvan bouquet
pourquoi pas attendre 2022 et les
prochaines élections présidentielles
pour se prononcer de manière
démocratique par les urnes en tout cas
ça fait déjà 20 ans que c'était que
cette jeune génération attend un
changement de politique
l'abbé culot révise mail avec une forme
de transition qui a été celle de
penneteau on était restés un peu moins
moins radicale un moment extrémistes ou
raison mais que le retour des 22 caisses
à fait
j'entends que cette société que les que
les colombiens et colombiennes vivent
sous l'oligarchie aurait visité sous son
modèle absolument violent est absolument
terrible et ils ont vu les conséquences
tous les jours et c'est malheureusement
les différentes réformes ont à la fois
mis le feu à la poudrière donc ce soit
la réforme de 2010 9 ou la réforme
fiscale qu'un contenu à d'énormes
manifestations mais vous avez eu non
plus une actualité récente du coc vite
vous avez 88 morts en colombie pour un
pays qui est deux fois plus petit que là
que la france vous avez presque
l'équivalent d'un de mort du co vide
cause notamment des réformes de santé
qui avait mis aux rives et c'est au
quotidien que ce vie les conséquences de
la politique uribiste dans le lycée au
quotidien vous avez des morts et d
assassiner politique en colombie depuis
2016 lehoux a dessiné les accords de
paix qui ne furent jamais respecté vous
avez plus d'un millier seulement depuis
2016 un millier d'opposants politiques
qui ont été assassinés depuis deux
semaines vous avez une quarantaine de
personnes qui ont été assassinées lors
des manifestations est prévue
plusieurs centaines je crois bien entre
400 et 500 disparus jeunes personnes qui
ont disparu at au quotidien que ces
personnes vivent le groupe c'est
justement à ce que vous pensez que ces
manifestants peuvent être entendus est
ce qu'ils peuvent obtenir le retrait de
ce système politique laurie big ben ou
est ce que c'est un système qui est bien
trop ancré en colombie est impossible et
bien à retirer ya encore une partie de
lui-même et elle est très fragilisée
depuis quelques années le ce que
représente pour ibis bon on va dire la
droite dure en ont dit que ce soit par
les différentes manifestations les
mouvements sociaux ou que ce soit par
les résultats électoraux vous voyez que
il est fragilisé et il est extrêmement
fragilisée
voire même vous avez récemment dans les
derniers sondages le personnage de
gustavo petro qui est le leader de
colombie à oman qui est leader pour le
moment dans les sondages et qui est
peut-être en passe de gagner dans les
élections présidentielles de 2022 c'est
bien qu'aujourd'hui le réalisme est de
plus en plus minoritaire après est ce
qu'il est possible de passer à un autre
modèle politique pour ça effectivement
il faudrait des élections qui se
tiennent dans de bonnes conditions qui
ne se passe ne se déroule pas avec une
violence politique des paramilitaires ou
des policiers et de l'origine des
narcotrafiquants et delory
de manière générale contre les opposants
politiques c'est ce que moi j'espérais
c'est ce que je demande
et aussi de notre part de ressortissants
qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas cons
longuet par exemple de la part de mon
parti politique ou ou d'autres ressorti
soir à travers le monde ce que nous
demandons et nous n'avons ou le lagon
exprimé à travers par exemple autre
communiqué
c'est déjà un message de la communauté
internationale s'intéresse pas d'être un
peu plus oui alors on en vient
rapidement sur ce silence de la
communauté internationale on peut le
nommer comme ça vous l'avez dit au moins
41 civils ont perdu la vie lors de ces
manifestations
comment on peut expliquer ce silence de
la communauté internationale
je peux vous dire que je ne me
l'expliqué pas moi même
on ne peut pas rester normalement hydro
normalement mais les principes
démocratiques et de respect des droits
humains
comment on n'arrête pas de nous
l'expliquer qu'on va parler par exemple
d'autres pays de l'amérique latine que
ce soit le le le venezuela ou autres
rester aveugle sur ce qui se passe au
congo vit on voit fin au cycle de la
même manière le parallèle pour ce qui
est en train de se passer sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien sur la bande de gaza
aujourd'hui la colombie est l'un des
principaux récepteurs des fonds
militaire américain et justement aussi
avec israël ça par exemple ça peut être
une piste pour entendre le silence de
une partie de la communauté
internationale qui s'était
malheureusement beaucoup trop alignées
sur le cas beaucoup d'intérêt en
colombie tout rappeler que nous avons
cette base militaire américaine en
colombie dont certaines qui sont aux
portes de bogota donc on porte du
pouvoir imaginez vous que nous ayons des
bases militaires aux portes de paris
donc effectivement c'est absolument
terrible le silence de la communauté
internationale de certains pays
européens et entre guillemets parce que
je n'aime pas ce terme de pays
développés ou qui entend je n'ai pas du
tout ces termes la scala le tiens à le
rappeler le silence aussi d'institutions
internationales l'union européenne est
absolument terrible et ce pour quoi nous
avons touché à sa fin
merci merci ian kelly fauqué rhin pour
pour cet éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire national du parti de
gauche et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine amérique du sud
merci